colleague from the chemistry department
david lemmer and he's going to tell you
about machine learning and
non-equilibrium systems
all right thank you very much
thank you for organizing this meeting in
person it's nice to be here
i guess as you all know well you learn
in proportional to a gradient of your
ignorance and i've been learning a lot
uh this last day and this morning
let's turn that off great
all right so
uh like michelle earlier today i'm a
physical scientist has been said i
sit about 200 yards over in that
direction in gilman hall
in a chemistry department
i consider myself very much a user of ml
techniques by far not an expert
so in thinking about what i could
possibly say concerning interpreting
machine learning
i thought probably the best thing i
could do is delve into a specific
example
where there's a physical problem we want
to solve
that we understand the structure of
quite well and then try to develop a
dictionary between the physical
statement of that problem and a
particular set of techniques in machine
learning specifically this will be
largely focused on reinforcement
learning techniques
the
perspective that i'll adopt is one from
statistical mechanics of non-equilibrium
systems so this is kind of what i spend
my day job thinking about
this is broadly speaking trying to
understand how collections of lots of
independent entities molecules usually
in my case
how they
collectively organize themselves to
allow for some emergent behavior
i will
talk largely
concretely about molecular systems
because that's what i tend to think
about
but by adopting
kind of a non-equilibrium perspective a
lot of the structure that we usually
invoke in chemistry departments i won't
assume so most of the models that i'll
talk about are broadly applicable not
just to molecular systems but to
you know climate systems so things on
much larger scales systems of
actual
you know animals moving around and how
they their patterns emerge things like
that
okay
so to ground this
concretely the kinds of problems that
i'm interested in are so-called rare
event problems
here are two concrete examples of such a
rare event problem this is a problem
where i have a representation of my
system maybe something mckelly has given
me was worked very hard to construct a
model for how molecules interact so i
have that model and i want to understand
something that's important but that
happens very infrequently
so two concrete examples of that might
be the auto ionization of water so water
you know a molecule that you drink
formed out of an oxygen a couple
hydrogens
you probably know that every once in a
while
if i evolve
water long enough
one of those molecules will fall apart
this is the origin of ph this is why
water has some acidity to it
this
behavior this
rare dynamical fluctuation that occurs
in water is incredibly infrequent if i
tag one water molecule and follow it
around during its life
it will take about 10 hours for that
molecule to fall apart
now 10 hours is maybe not a long time on
r scales but considering molecules
fundamental vibrations are on
picoseconds that's about
16 orders of magnitude different from
their kind of intrinsic time scales to
when this occurs
to illustrate that i'll note that the
duration of that movie is about a tenth
of a picosecond so that's how long it
takes for that event to occur
conditioned on it occurring
but the time in between subsequent
events is 10 hours
similarly if i wanted to fold a protein
you know the characteristic times for a
given protein starting in a denatured
state to adopt some characteristic
structure can span from milliseconds to
seconds maybe even hours
while the time it takes to actually
funnel into that particular structure is
relatively quick maybe only 100
nanoseconds
so we want to understand these sorts of
rare events so you can imagine that we
have statistical problems associated
with getting enough realizations of that
event so we'd like some tools to be able
to do that efficiently
and there's some simplifications that
were afforded i've kind of alluded to
that even on the previous slide that
even though
the kinds of events were interested are
rare they typically occur very
fleetingly so condition on them
happening
i don't actually have to evolve the
dynamics very long to actually see the
event
that's summarized physically in a
statement of the separation of time
scales
given i'm going to overcome some
barriers some dynamical bottleneck
the time it takes to transition is small
refer to that as delta c
even even if the characteristic waiting
time between events is large
so that allows us to characterize these
events with a single number a rate
constant that's the probability of the
event occurring per unit time
now the standard techniques for trying
to understand these sorts of problems in
a chemistry physics department
either try to avoid actually looking at
dynamics themselves because they realize
that this is a hard problem they try to
find
where the characteristic bottlenecks
might be so if i imagine the
ball bearing moving around in this
potential well i need to get it to the
top of the hill for it to fall down so
they just try to locate that hill
that works when you have a lot of
intuition as to what direction you might
push that ball up the hill but in high
dimensional systems
that chemical intuition can break down
and it can can be hard to find the right
direction to push
moreover there could be a massive
degeneracy in the number of ways that
that event can occur
and so we would like some way some kind
of model or intuition agnostic means of
understanding these sorts of yes
questions
not life science is that
um what what exactly like
do we mean by push here like what is
that yeah it's a it's a drip and a
in the distribution of configurations
and practically speaking in a lot of the
cases we'll talk about it's a force
right
so that actually gets me to
this specific point so
what we want to do very specifically to
state the task is i want to
have my system transition from some
collection of states maybe a set of
unfolded states a label is a
system statement set of states b may be
characterized by some overlap with a
native structure
and physical dynamics are markovian so
that simplifies some things so i can
define a trajectory as a sequence of
snapshots of states along this
trajectory and because it's markovian i
can write down the measure of that
trajectory distribution probability of
observing some trajectories probability
of starting somewhere and then all the
subsequent transition probabilities
what i would like to do
is to generate those reactive
trajectories directories that go from a
to b
typically i want to have a means of
generating lots of them so i can go and
look at them i can ask how do they occur
i can quantify the rates of those events
yes
[Music]
okay so
overall there's kind of two ways to talk
about these questions okay so the
question is what is what do i mean by
rare
in sense of overall i'm going to
interpret that as meaning
that we have in some sense two extents
of the system we have a time direction
if i wait long enough i can see
something happen there's also a spatial
direction i have lots of copies of a
protein maybe if it's macroscopically
large the likelihood that any one of
them in even even a infinite testimony
amount of time something's happened is
that kind of what you're asking
all the time
so so we microscopic beings will see
this where i'm thinking about things
that do happen frequently on our time
skills but on the time scales over which
the dynamics are naturally discretized
molecular time scales there is a gulf of
separation so
you know that autoionization event
the fundamental motions occur on
picoseconds or femtoseconds
the molecule falls apart an hour so
that's 10 to the 20 orders of magnitude
different so if i'm going to simulate
the system i need to resolve the finite
times and so i'm never going to be able
to evolve my dynamics long enough to see
the event
okay
all right so
i want to generate these reactive
trajectories
so i could formulate this sharply as a
task where
i want to try to invent a new dynamics a
dynamics that knows about this objective
that makes this process typical
so because this is a markovian dynamics
it's the dynamics are governed by some
transition kernel i could try to
introduce or find a new transition curl
that make transitions kernel that makes
this happen
and this is an exact rewaiting i just
multiply by one to do this i have to
introduce this factor here a ratio of
these
original transition probabilities and
the new transition probability i'm
trying to find
and so then i have to sharpen this task
a little bit i want to not only find a
set of transition probabilities that
will affect this transition this
reaction from a to b but i want to do it
in a way that is the most like the way
the system would have naturally evolved
that fluctuation
that's a
statement that i want to minimize the
overlap between
these transition kernels are the
product of all of these transitions
okay
so the task is
starting a want to get to b
you all probably will appreciate that
this is a standard task in
rl and reinforcement learning
for example if you just google around a
little bit you'll find a nice website by
this guy here
showing how you can use something he
calls q learning which i have no idea
what it means probably some of you here
do
where you can solve a maze so maze is
just a set of walls where this little
agent a mouse in this case can't pass so
i want to start an a here and then b
there you can find the set of actions
transition elements
given your at some state
it tells you which way you should go in
order to succeed in finding the solution
to this maze
so in my case
the agent is some subset of the degrees
of freedom that i'm particularly
interested in maybe the protein itself
maybe not all the surrounding water that
it's interacting with
so there's a state of the system there's
an environment which is the subset not
included in that agent
the action that i want to find is the
set of transition probabilities
and the reward is some
progress coordinate or some reporter on
whether or not at the end of the day
i've made it to the place i want to be
the folded state concretely or some
generic state b
and so i want to try to find
these policies in a policy gradient
based approach
that get me from some unfolded state to
the folded state
so this is
cast in the reinforcement learning
language
in a physical or chemical language
we can talk about that rate constant the
number that quantifies how likely i am
to see that transition per unit time
as essentially an on a partition
function a summation over all paths
with some conditioning
so conditioned on starting in a and in a
b i want to sum over all the paths
up to some constants on the front that
tells me how likely that
rare event is to happen
in a lot of the physical systems i'm
interested in that exist in both
continuous space and continuous time i
can write down
that path probability has this specific
form
so
there are factors associated with the
temperature of the heat mass it's in
the velocities of which those particles
move and forces or drifts that move
things from place to place
deterministically
and because the system is big and
complicated there is noise
generated from the environment that
makes this probabilistic it's not a
deterministic kernel that says once i
know where i start
i'm uniquely mapped to some final point
but there's some spread
okay
so
you're trying to like
you're you have some action under your
power and you want to
cause this particular transition to
happen
just like like what exactly like what is
just so i have zom says being kind of
ignorant of the methods
like what is the nature of the
intervention that you have you said like
apply some kind of force
like just
just physically like what like what
instrument are you using applying to
this approach so this is all in a
computer so i'm a theorist
so i can define any set of
pair interactions or potentials that i
could add between the particles and in
fact that transition
so this is not me having some very
limited amount of control you can think
about this as nearly fully controlled i
can act on any subset of uh
parts of the system representing a force
in a full configuration space in a whole
internet dimensional space
and acts
upon those sorry it's a simulation
yes
i'm using a molecular dynamic simulation
i'm solving newton's equations of motion
given some fair potential metallication
and is there some real world action that
this might potentially correspond to
like let's say you find that there is
some hypothetical set of forces that you
in the simulation where you could play
god you can apply
like when they saw an instrument i could
sort of
maybe implement something like that
potentially like actually cause a
protein
to fold in a desired way or sure uh
though that's not exactly what i have in
mind to solve so i'm
trying to
build a computational technique that
will see these events given that i
assume that the model that i'm using the
interactions are sufficiently reliable
that they are a good measure of reality
in principle you could
you could walk over to my colleague
carlos usmante who does use optical
tweezers to affect transitions between
proteins
though that is very limited control i
can control one degree of freedom in the
system so usually the sorts of
techniques that i'll talk about here
would be massively
overkill because i could you know just
essentially brute force up that nice
pulling rate in time to solve this
problem
and then i think this is not an
important company yeah this is an
important sample on a space of
trajectories that's exactly
so
as i say this is just important i have a
trajectory space
i have some space where the thing that
i'm interested in happening is unlikely
i want to find a new set of dynamical
rules that makes that unlikely event
typical and if i do this just right
i don't have to
rewrite my trajectory space if i find an
ideal important sampler i could just
generate trajectories with these new
forces
and one can sharply write down a
variational statement of what optimal
means in this case an optimal added set
of forces that move my system from a to
b
through an application of so this
rewiting principle on trajectory spaces
for a stochastic process is a gears
enough rewaiting
i can
write this
quantity as an average over this
rewaiting factor this change of
stochastic action with this new drift
as an expectation value and apply the
convexity of the exponential to bound
that observable i'm interested in the
rate constant of this process by just
that change
in stochastic action in this case the kl
divergence between the driven trajectory
ensemble and the one that's just
conditioned to go from a to b
so then the game is using
techniques of rl to try to
maximize this kl divergence try to find
the best overlap between those two minus
the
scale that we're just trying to maximize
the overlap between the two
distributions trajectories that are
driven and those that are just
conditioned
yes
is that is that done by the individual
part
is that done by the individual um
particles or are they are they the ones
that are sensing and reacting to
the environment or i guess you know you
might discuss how you're not you're not
like controlling these are simulations
you're not controlling anything what if
is the rl being done by the individual
by each individual particle or
circuit yeah so so the best thing i
could maybe just talk very concretely
about a specific example so imagine i
have a particle that's moving around in
this potential so the blue potential
here and i want to see this particle
interacting with the back that i'm not
showing you that causes random noises to
be added to it i want to see that
particle go from this well to that
so
this variational statement here says
that there should be there might exist a
set of new tricks instead of new forces
that that particles experiences
parameterized in time so it might be a
time dependent potential that will
affect that transition and do so in an
optimal way and by optimal i mean
with a
best kale divergence between these two
trajectory ensembles
and so in principle that's some
complicated force i don't know what it's
going to be but i could try to use rl to
optimize it i could try to express that
function so this new drift
on this coordinate
in some complicated way so these are
some functions maybe they're gaussians
or
in time and in space with optimizable
coefficients and i could try to solve
this by
extremizing this kl divergence this
relative action and i can do that by
writing down explicit gradients these
are
time correlation functions averaged
within the reactive ensemble of
trajectories
what you get is something like this so
what you find is that the optimal
potential so this is a just a two
two-dimensional system that's not so
hard you can't express
uh you can fully represent the
the all the degrees of freedom in just
some small basis
there's a space
direction and a time direction and what
you get is a potential that essentially
does maybe what you might naively expect
it just
pushes up this minimum and tilts the
particle over so it falls into the well
turns out to actually
use gradients like this directly uh is
ill pose these are fluctuating
quantities becomes very difficult to
converge them and so i the
identification so to be completely
transparent you know we derive this
algorithm ourselves before we realized
we were doing reinforcement learning
that realization was incredibly useful
because there's been lots of techniques
using value baseline value functions
to minimize the variance in gradient
optimization that we're able to import
have made that identification and
actually
enhance the training
of these forces
significantly to the place where this is
now possible as opposed to being
difficult
characteristic learning curve comparing
just naive gradients this is we call it
monte carlo returns compared to a value
baseline type of approach
so
putting in a little bit more physics
into what we're doing maybe to help
answer some of the questions that have
come up
it it it turns out that this
optimization problem finding a drift
that
carries a system between two endpoints
in a way in which the system would
naturally have generated that
fluctuation
is a solved problem
in the sense that an optimum is known to
exist this is a generalized brownian
bridge problem so if i have any
stochastic differential equation
where i have some
drift term
some
time dependent potential or force and
some say gaussian noise
i can write down the optimal force that
i would add to the system to affect the
transition and it takes this form
this kernel here is a solution of a
backward chromograph equation associated
with that stochastic sde
that's math there's a very simple
picture that that relates to
the optimal force
is what you find by starting the system
in the state you want to get to so some
b some localized initial condition
and evolving it backwards in time so if
i started the system as a delta function
distribution
and evolved it under the potential this
dashed line
what you'd find is that it would relax
it would first broaden and then start
sensing that other minima before it
eventually realize the stationary
distribution
affected by essentially flipping the
potential upside down and taking its
exponential
doing that taking the log and the
grading then gives you what that optimal
force is so that's what you saw on the
previous slide it really is just running
the dynamics backwards in time that's
the optimal drift i would add the system
to effect the transition
that doesn't mean that this is now an
easy problem because in principle
we're interested in systems that are
that live in a very high dimension you
know if i'm thinking about this protein
folding problem this is a
space of
three in degrees of freedom that force
then in principle lives in all of that
space plus time so i still need to have
a nice compact representation or
functional representation of the force
that i can learn
just to talk a little bit more about
what these
things that we're actually doing in the
training means so this is essentially a
statement of
the
interpretability of the answer we get
out we know that if we have find it
found an optimal drift what that means
is that it's the solution of this
backward formal growth equation it's the
relaxation process
in the time reverse direction
to understand
the learning process itself
we can take note of
properties of the kl divergence
essentially the cost function that we're
working with in this
essentially regularized
reinforcement learning approach so
regularized in the sense that we're not
just trying to see the transition we're
trying to see the transition
in the
as close to possible way as the system
would have generated it naturally
so the kl divergence naturally is
decomposed based on its time reversal
symmetry properties so it turns out if i
take
the relative action
between a forward and time process and a
backwards in time process this is what
you mean by the heat that's dissipated
into an environment that is if the
transitions are mediated by a thermal
bath
that's always the case when you have a
physical system even if this is not a
physical dynamics like i'm imagining a
markov process that has some noise where
the transitions are
not constrained by some sort of detail
balance if i take
differences of relative actions there's
still a
representation of that part of the kl
divergence
as an entropy production and an increase
of the space of possible trajectories
that i can observe
the symmetric part of the action
what we call the activity is the amount
of excess dynamics that occurs
in the presence of this optimal drift
so this is the jitter around some
enduring displacement if
entropy production is like a current
times some force that generates the
current the activity is all the
diffusion around that
it turns out that these sorts of
transition problems are bounded from
above by the heat that's a consequence
of this being related to an entropy
production this is kind of like a second
statement of the second law
and the gradients we use in the
optimization have
so-called generalized fluctuation
dissipation relationships namely those
gradients are expressible as time
correlation functions of physical
observables
so this tells you about
the total amount of displacement in the
system
the
friction the force force correlation
functions and
this is the energy injected to the
system so if
the
markov process that i'm considering is
detailed balance so it exists it will
generate a stationary distribution of a
boltzmann or generalized kind of gibbs
form
it turns out that only these red terms
will persist everything else comes about
from the system not obeying detailed
balance okay and then just to end on a
couple more concrete examples
so here's an example of browning motion
and a potential where i have two
potential paths to go between a and b
where in addition to just browning
motion on the surface
i have a so-called active propulsion
so it turns out this is a model for a
colloid that has a little jet pack
attached to it so it likes to propagate
in one direction
it's not so different from a model of a
human trying to exit a room where
there's a distinction between a forward
and a backwards direction i tend to
walk forward in place instead of
backwards in place
but i randomly reorient as well as
randomly
translate you can solve for this uh the
optimal drift here we use a deep neural
network to parametrize that drift
as opposed to other functional
representations
uh we can converge the rate and we can
ask then because we know the structure
of this problem we know that this
loss function decomposes into
contributions that depend on the
different coordinates we're biasing on
so the x direction where i'm actually
trying to go
some orthogonal direction which is
irrelevant
and then some theta direction that tells
me about how the
orientation of this particle changes
this is the drift as a function of time
it tries to skirt me around what is a
big hill in the middle
and as the time gets larger
i'm
conditioning on ending at some final
time so if i s somehow still over here
before
epsilon you know epsilon minus when i
need to be over there i'll just get
pushed over there
a slightly more complicated example
is a molecule in one of these active
solutes or solvents
where it can exist in two different
conformations some compact conformation
some extended confirmation
i want to now find the force in this
higher dimensional space which makes
this transition like that
typical
so we can parameterize that we can ask
how much is kind of energetic in the
sense of just enduring displacement
parts and how much is activity parts
and do that decomposition as a function
of the
speed of which these
uh these molecules move
so i'll go ahead and
so what i tried to do is draw in a
specific example a correspondence
between
what would be a kind of black box
technique a policy gradient like
technique and identify the terms and
what they mean physically and in doing
that we both
can then understand how best to use some
of the extensions of naive rl techniques
as well as
have a method that actually we find very
useful for studying these sorts of rare
event problems
you know just to close on a point that
you know again i've talked about this in
the context of atoms and molecules but
these same techniques are actively being
used to understand rare weather events
if i have a dynamical system i want to
stand understand how likely it is for a
hurricane to pop into existence the same
mark off processes and the same optimal
drifts can be used to import and sample
those
dynamical events too
okay
thank you all for your time
thank you uh
so
i was interested in understanding um
so
the physical equations
um tell you that you should be using
some exponential of a potential function
as your
transition function
that
like that models the evolution between
markovian states
um
how do you um
i guess what do you use in your rl
framework to model that transition
function it seems to me that you were
using a neural network but it's unclear
how
to i guess um
how to interpret that neural network as
an exponential of a potential function
right so
sorry this is probably me being unclear
so i don't actually model the transition
probability itself
i
recognize the structure of that
transition probability depends
exponentially
so that transition kernel can be written
like this there's a friction piece so
some number a velocity and a force
so this force is the only three
parameters so that's what i mod i model
the actual force itself and then that
gets put into the transition kernel
so then that gives interpretability
because i'm going to decompose the force
that's acting on the part
any questions
again the transition to the kind of
discussion